[Musique]
des bouteilles aux allures de spiritueux
avec des noms des couleurs à s'y
méprendre la couleur est quand même
intéressante des odeurs qui trouve les
sens ça sent cette nouvelle quand on est
pratiquement la copie y est l'équivalent
alcoolique
mais toutes ces bouteilles sont en fait
des spiritueux sans alcool ces produits
du québec et d'ailleurs se multiplient
sur les tablettes des épiceries et de la
saq on sait qu aux etats unis ce marché
si les boissons alcalay non alcoolique
cea représente environ 350 millions
présentement mais c'est qu'on a une
vélocité une augmentation une croissance
très intéressante de l'ordre de 10 à 30%
selon les catégories à titre d'exemple
il ya quelques semaines la chanteuse
katie perry à se lancer lancé dans la
mêlée avec un produit ou tout le
marketing est fait autour de l'aspect
ludique l'aspect phone
donc on est vraiment dans une logique de
se comparer aux équivalents alcoolique
j'étais très impliqué par l'avocat sans
alcool parce que ce jeu façon de
comprendre l'intérêt d'un produit neutre
la mode que ça produit un alcool notre
goût aux saveurs je me demande qu'est ce
que ça va coûter
rossi marc et mixologue et aux tris de
deux livres sur les cocktails au québec
on lui a demandé de goûter à différentes
boissons et de nous donner ses
impressions
il ya vraiment un côté piquant c'est
quelque chose qui se retrouve beaucoup
dans les spiritueux sans alcool vont
essayer de trouver un aromate qui veut
donner ce petit côté là de chaleur en
bouche ok certainement utiliser des
piments des poivres est différente et de
produits pour venir créer cette
sensation le de brûlures et dans celui
là on le vraiment beaucoup
[Musique]
selon rose ce spiritueux s'utilise
surtout pour faire des mélanges pour
faire des mortel s'est produit le c'est
pas un fin produits de dégustation
il n'y a pas la chaleur que l'alcool
procure en bouche il pas tout la
dimension vite leur un peu de l'alcool
je dois la texture de l'alcool on la
ressent pas c'est quand même sur une
base d'eau je pense que c'est bon un
mélange
l'engouement pour ces produits est
propulsé par la tendance du naulleau un
mouvement populaire qui veut dire pas ou
peu d'alcool
pourtant le nombre de consommateurs
d'alcool reste stable ça fait 40 ans
qu'au québec
85% des personnes âgées de 15 ans et
plus sont des consommateurs d'alcool et
ça n'a pas bronché pas plus tard que le
mois dernier alors que les gens aient
arrêté faut que les gens boivent
différemment réponse oui en bout le
gouvernail et dans les roms donc ça se
reproduit assez facilement et le petit
côté puis quand cette fois-ci effet take
du poivron mais je peux convaincu du
goût de poivrons
tu vois lui gelé ses rangs côté tout
l'aspect naturalité on vient bien jouer
là dessus sur les étiquettes en mettant
des ingrédients naturels souvent locaux
pour venir séduire le consommateur ou
sacs butin plus est la feuille de
laurier andré est vraiment rien qui
reste en bouche donc c'est très très
fade c'est good book ou l'eau aromatisée
pour la majorité des produits le premier
ingrédient et de l'eau ces boissons
affiche obligatoirement les ingrédients
y la valeur nutritive contrairement aux
produits alcoolisés
c'est vraiment convaincant c'est
vraiment très sucrées par exemple ça dix
ans g de sucre pas pour 3 cuillères à
soupe mais l'amaretto avec alcool c'est
très très sucré aussi
certaines boissons contiennent du sucre
comme l'amaretto où les apéritifs mais
dans l'ensemble ils ont peu ou pas de
calories si on fait un moteur essence et
produits le si on veut remplacer
l'alcool aurait utilisé un jus varrault
du ce donc ça nous permet de venir a
ajouté un ingrédient sans ajouter de
sucre on commence à se tourner vers des
options qui sont souvent perçues plus
santé et plus socialement acceptable si
on veut pas nécessairement prendre
d'alcool pour toutes sortes de raisons
on a commencé à
détruire cette espèce de mythe que les
gens qui ne boivent pas sont des cas
ceux de parts et si vous me passez
l'expression
quelqu'un qui a décidé de ne pas boire
n'a pas à se justifier de ne pas boire
quand quelqu'un ne fume pas on lui
demande pas pourquoi tu fume pas c'est
une des grandes recommandations qu'il
faut faire c'est donner le choix aux
gens qui ne veulent pas boire d'alcool
de notre collection de jeans
valérian croix s'intéresse à la
découverte des jeans il a vu la tendance
des spiritueux sans alcool en europe et
a décidé de développer le premier jean
sans alcool québécois le hp juni perd on
n'est pas des alcoolisées pour moi c'est
très important de utiliser les mêmes
ingrédients les mêmes équipements puis
les mêmes procédés que pour la création
des spiritueux et les une conventionnel
donc on utilise un alambic en cuivre
dans lequel on fait d'ici les as roma de
botanique naturel entre autres la baie
de genévrier qui était essentielle aux
jeans on essaie de mettre en valeur
principalement la baie de genévrier qui
ont aussi les agrumes et puis dans le
col de flora long de tout le bouquet de
fleurs qui est présent dans les premiers
balbutiements de cette catégorie là on
essayait beaucoup de se différencier
pour faire valoir consommateurs qui
avaient des choses qu'on avait enlevé du
produit que ce soit le taux de sucre
d'alcool ecce terra maintenant on est
plus dans cette logique là on vient même
imiter le produit traditionnel certains
disques bah si c'est pas du jeans ça
devrait pas s'appeler du jane et il y à
des enjeux légaux partout à travers le
monde 38 dollars 50 quand même porté
le prix est aussi comparable à un
spiritueux nous avons payé de 20 à 45
dollars la bouteille pourtant les
fabricants n'ont pas à payer la taxe
imposée sur les boissons alcoolisées il
faut savoir aussi que la durée de
conservation est d'environ trois mois
après l'ouverture
selon valait rien c'est la complexité de
la fabrication qui explique le prix est
à tout le coût des produits utilisés et
puis aussi l'équipement utilisé c'est un
investissement considérable
différentes raisons nous incite à la
sobriété et il faut le faire de façon
régulière selon monsieur ça si le mois
en grande-bretagne où il se vend le plus
d'alcool s'est rendu le mois de février
parce que tous ceux qui sont arrêtés de
war en janvier ils se re précipite dans
l'alcool au bout du mois il est
préférable de faire deux ou trois jours
d'abstinence par semaine que un mois
d'abstinence par année
parmi les spiritueux sans alcool que
rose a préféré dans notre échantillon
elle s'est inspirée et propose trois
cocktails à base de jean d'amaretto et
d'un apéritif
l'amertume de d'apéritif on vient
vraiment donner un effet placebo comme
sauvée de l'alcool fumer trois tests
sont quand même convaincu
il y a de plus en plus cette tendance à
alterner boissons alcoolisées et
boissons non alcoolisées et pas toutes
les occasions je pense que dans une
soirée ainsi je m'ai fait servir un
cocktail comme celui de jeu très
satisfaite puis-je et j'y prends
plaisait aussi à aalborg